All right, lines A and D existed in the original file.
And there still in both Jake and Rachel's versions.
So will mark those as yes.
Now let's think about all these B's.
Both Jake and Rachel probably had reasons for
changing it to what they did, but we don't know which one was right.
The two of them will probably need to get together to discuss which one
should go in the final version.
As for line B itself, you could argue that since both Jake and
Rachel modified this line, it should definitely be removed.
You could also argue that after discussing their changes,
they might just decide that they want to keep the original after all.
So let's mark this as unknown.
Both of these are reasonable answers.
The important thing to notice is that we're not sure which version of B
should be present in the final file.